we all remember eating Mr Noodles pretty
much every single day breakfast lunch
and dinner as college kids did you ever
eat them just raw in the back of the bag
that was like the only way I ate them
but today I'm going to show you how to
make them into a hunger potion combo
step number one I'm using bone broth for
some extra flavor and a lot of extra
protein as well
noodle them
so how come you didn't put the pocket in
I just felt just feel there's enough
chicken flavor in the bone broth and I'm
gonna add a little splash of coconut
aminos and some sesame oil as well
now I've just got some leftover
stir-fried veg from last night's dinner
and some rotisserie chicken the little
hard-boiled egg and some sesame seeds we
got protein in the bone broth Chicken
and the Egg we've got lots of fiber in
the sauteed veg plus we've got some
healthy fats in the sesame oil and
sesame seeds on top and the Egg I'm
pretty excited about this and it
literally took me five minutes to make
here you go Freddy all right I'm good I
think I'm just gonna eat them raw